>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> STEPHANIE MARCUS: Good
morning and welcome to the sixth
of our eight lectures this
year in our NASA series.
We've got a couple of exciting
ones coming up, but I'm not going
to tell you about them because
we have a little sheet outside
on the table that tells
you what they are.
I'm Stephanie Marcus
from the Science,
Technology and Business division.
And Sean Bryant and I
coordinate this series.
And it's our tenth year.
So, we're having a great time
and we're never going to stop.
I imagine nobody here
today is too pleased
with the weather we're having, but
our speaker Alex Young is going
to tell us about the really
nasty weather you might encounter
when you book your trip to Mars.
Dr. Young's educational
background includes a BS in Physics
from Florida State University,
a Master's in Physics
from the University of New
Hampshire, and also his PhD
in Physics is from the
University of New Hampshire.
After grad school, he came
to NASA at some point,
and was a solar astrophysicist
and worked
on the NASA European
Space Agency SOHO Mission.
I love the way they
name these missions,
they're always pretty cool.
The SOHO was the Solar and
Heliospheric Observatory.
His current position is
associate director for science
in the Heliophysics Science
Division at NASA Goddard
and he is responsible
there for overseeing
and coordinating the education
and public outreach
team for the division.
But he says now they
pretty much reach
out for all the space sciences
divisions as well as his.
But he continues his research
in the science of space weather.
And he's very much into
solar image processing.
Besides giving lectures,
like this one, and doing TV
and radio interviews and also
Discovery Channel documentaries,
Dr. Young has established
a website, thesuntoday.org
and it has a companion
Facebook page.
And he's also on Twitter
and YouTube.
So, check him out.
The suntoday.
And now let's get on with
the space weather report.
And welcome Dr. Young.
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: All right.
Thank you.
>> STEPHANIE MARCUS:
You're welcome [applause].
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: Thank
you everyone.
I have to say it's going to be
a little bit difficult for me.
I'm used to moving around.
I don't really stand
still when I give talks.
But I was told because they're
doing the webcast, I have to force
in the urge to get out
and express myself.
So, hopefully I won't
knock anything over.
Because I tend to talk about
big explosions and use my arms.
But I want to give you a little
bit of perspective into weather,
not here on earth,
but weather in space
in an area we call space weather.
My area of research is
in solar astrophysics.
I've, for about 12 years, studies
large explosions on the sun,
other starts as well as their impact
through the solar system
and here on earth.
And then after that, as was
mentioned, I got more involved
in education and public outreach.
But I still do some research.
Right now, for example, I'm looking
at the impacts of space weather
on data centers, working with, for
example, Google to see what sort
of possible impacts it could
have here, on the ground.
But what I want to do today is just
give you a little bit of an overview
and a look at the whole aerospace
weather, where the sun comes
into play, and what sort of
implications that has for the earth,
for us here on earth,
but in addition
through the entire solar system.
Because one of the things that's
really important for NASA,
in addition to just human
spaceflight is the fact
that we have a lot of technology
scattered through the solar system.
Because we're interested in
looking at all sorts of things.
Everything from planets,
to comets and asteroids.
And the impacts of space
weather, not just here on earth,
but also on the technology that we
have throughout the solar system.
And so, that's one of the areas
that's very important to NASA.
But to start off, so I want
you to indulge me for a second
and think a little bit about what
is it you think about the sun.
You know what is your thought
of the sun on a daily basis.
Close your eyes, maybe, and when you
think about the sun, maybe you think
about sunrise or sunset, or
you know, what's your sort
of general thoughts about it.
Now, this may be the kind
of image that comes to mind.
Or even let's say you
put a camera up,
you might get something like this.
There's all kinds of
cool things you can see.
Sometimes you can see
halos around the sun
from ice crystals,
that sort of stuff.
But also, you may think about it
as, let's say you have a telescope
and you do some safe solar
viewing, with appropriate kind
of filter, look at the sun.
You may see something
a little bit like this.
Still, it's not really
that exciting.
It's kind of boring.
Sort of a yellow disk.
If you look at it long enough,
you'll notice there are things
that are moving across the surface.
These are called sunspots.
You can sometimes see them with
the naked eye with solar glasses
like the ones that are outside.
If you look up at the sun,
when there's a large enough
sunspot, you can see these.
To give you some perspective, this
is about the size of the earth,
that sunspot right there, okay?
That's a decent size sunspot.
Not too big, not too small.
The other thing you notice here,
which you don't necessarily
notice maybe
on a daily basis is we see
the sun move through the sky,
but you may not even
think about the fact
that it rotates, just
like other planets.
The sun is spinning.
We're rotating around it,
but it is also spinning.
Now, there is one time when you
can really see something more
interesting on the sun and that
is during a total solar eclipse.
So, the first time
that humans realized
that there's a little bit
more interesting stuff going
on is not just these sunspots,
but something like this.
Okay. So here the moon has blocked
out the sun almost completely.
And you will see there's
a little spot there.
This actually doesn't quite show
up, but this is in fact red.
If you look at that, that
little piece that's sticking
out on the edge there is red.
You see all this structure.
Now, this is cheating a little bit,
they've taken a couple
images and overlaid them.
You will see this wispy structure
if you look at it from the ground,
you don't quite see
this fine detail.
But you will see this sort of
wispy halo structure that comes
out of the sun during this
brief period we call totality,
when it is in fact safe
to look at the sun.
If you are, I'm sure you've
all heard you should never look
at the sun without the
appropriate equipment or glasses,
or filters if you're
using a telescope.
But in fact, during a total
solar eclipse, usually a period
of somewhere between
a couple minutes,
maybe the longest one
recently was about 7 minutes,
it is safe to look at the sun.
And this is something you would
see only with your naked eye.
You would not see this if
you used those solar glasses.
They would completely
block this out.
As a matter of fact, you wouldn't
see anything with the solar glasses
on during the total solar eclipse.
But you see all this
structure, and this was sort
of the first indication that there's
something interesting going on.
The sun is a little bit
more exciting than this sort
of this yellow disk in the sky.
But if we step outside
of our atmosphere.
Let's go up into space, use a
spacecraft, and telescopes in space
to look at the sun, we get
a different perspective.
This is what we see.
This is a lot different than
what it looks like on the ground.
Now, in this case you see there's
all of this amazing structure
and everywhere you look on the
sun there's something happening.
From the tiniest scales you can see
to the things almost the
size of the entire sun.
You see, when there is this
flash, you'll see this flash
of light when it recycles.
And you see this structure
that looks like it's moving
across the whole sun,
that is in fact a wave.
There is an explosion that sends
a wave across the entire surface
of the sun traveling several
million miles an hour.
That's a result of
that explosion you saw.
So, that flash you
saw was a solar flare.
An extremely intense
release of energy of light
over the entire spectrum.
Okay, not just the visible
spectrum that we see, but everything
from infrared, to radio
to do microwave,
or in the other direction,
ultraviolet,
extreme ultraviolet,
x-rays, even gamma rays.
So, the sun puts out energy through
the entire electromagnetic spectrum.
So, that was a solar flare.
But you also see all of this
stuff moving and wiggling around.
And you see right here
something moves.
There's a big structure that
actually erupts from the sun.
We're going to look at it shortly
from a different perspective.
It's kind of hard to see
from this perspective.
But you're actually going to see
things flying away from the sun.
What's happening here is not
only is the sun exploding
and releasing this
light, the solar flare.
But it's actually throwing off
billions of tons of its material
at many millions of miles an hour.
It's traveling away from the
sun through the solar system.
Sometimes to us, sometimes
to other parts.
The other thing, and this is where
I tend to want to run out and try
to show you with my arms.
I'll try to do this
without going anywhere.
But, when that big blast of
material comes away from the sun,
it's traveling so fast,
it's scooping up everything
in front of it.
Because space is actually not empty.
And I'll talk more about that.
There's particles and
there's material out there
and it get scooped up like a
snowplow and pushed incredibly fast.
And there's also this huge blast
of particles that get accelerated
to near the speed of light.
And I'll show you what
that looks like shortly.
But those are three
parts of space weather.
So, there's the flash, the solar
flare, enough energy is released
in a moderate size solar
flare to power the world,
the entire globe for 100,000 years.
Okay? And now if you want to
get in terms of explosions,
that billions of atomic bombs.
Of World War II size atomic bombs.
That's the amount of
energy released in that.
The amount of energy released
in that stuff that's thrown out,
we call that a coronal
mass ejection.
The outer atmosphere of the
sun is called the corona.
And this is just mass,
stuff that's thrown out.
It's not just material, but it's
also magnetic fields and I'll talk
about that soon, because that's a
very key feature, magnetic fields.
That coronal mass ejection
has almost as much,
or if not more energy
sometimes than that flare.
And then there's those particles
that are accelerated away.
So, those are three
parts of space weather.
And we'll talk a little bit
about what the implications
of those are, what they do.
But why do we want to look
at the sun from space?
Well, you can see here,
there's an awful lot
of structure you see
that's happening.
It turns out that when you go
into space and you use a set
of telescopes that look at
different wavelengths of light,
you can see the sun is
vastly different depending
on the wavelength of
light you look at.
So, this yellow part is the
visible sun, you see the sunspots.
But as we move around
we go from ultraviolet
to extreme ultraviolet,
to near x-ray energies.
And you see as you're cycling
around, you see that depending
on the wavelength of light,
what you see is very different.
Now, these colors are artificial,
because really we're looking at part
of light that's not visible.
So, color, there really is no color.
They're actually black and
white or grayscale images,
but we've colored them, because
that tells us as a scientist,
I can look at any one of
those colors and I know
which wavelength of light that is.
And why is that important?
Because each one of these not only
shows us different structures,
what it in fact is showing is
different temperatures of the sun.
So, the surface of the sun
here is about 10,000 degrees,
but as we move up this
is about 20,000.
This is somewhere between
40 to 80,000.
This is a million.
This is 10 million degrees.
So, as you move out from the surface
of the sun, the visible surface,
you're actually going
up in temperature.
So, you're also moving
higher in the atmosphere.
Okay. So, this outer part, all of
this part here, this is the corona.
The part that you saw during
the total solar eclipse.
But now, we're seeing all of
those wispy structures and detail,
you're seeing it actually
connect back to the sun,
because before you were just
seeing, not the disk of the sun,
but sort of the outer atmosphere.
Okay. So, that's why
we go out in space.
Because for example,
watch that sunspot
and see how it changes
as you move around.
It actually gets brighter right
here, it's brighter there.
Here's another thing, you'll
notice these loop like structures
and we're going to come back to
that, but in fact those are related
to these magnetic fields
that I was talking about.
So, let's look at some detail
in these different wavelengths.
I'm going to pick a couple
of them, one that's going
to show us the million degrees
and one that's going to show us
about the 80,000, 100,000 degrees.
So, this is roughly
a million degrees.
All of these bright patches
are where the sunspots are.
We're now looking in extreme
ultraviolet, not visible light,
and where they were dark in visible
light, they're actually very bright,
because they're very hot.
And so, that the material
is glowing.
It is so hot that it's glowing.
Millions of degrees.
And then you see these loops.
Those are magnetic fields.
Now, magnetic fields you know
the invisible force that you feel
when you take a magnet and stick it
on your refrigerator and it holds it
to the refrigerator, that's
an invisible force, but here,
we're not actually seeing
the magnetic fields directly,
we're seeing the material follow
along the magnetic fields.
Magnetic fields are invisible,
but the material the sun is made
up of is electromagnetic.
It responds to magnetic fields.
And so, the magnetic fields collect
that stuff, that material on the sun
and it traces them out,
so you can see them.
Normally you wouldn't
be able to see them.
Now, just so you know that
material is called a plasma.
We won't go into the
details of that,
but that's actually what
happens when you heat something
up to super, super
high temperatures.
It actually goes from, if you take
for example water, starts off as ice
when it's very cold, that's a solid.
You heat it up a little
bit, it turns into a liquid.
You heat it up even more
it turns into a gas.
Well, if you heat it up a lot more,
it actually turns into a plasma
and that's the fourth
state of matter.
So, there are four states of matter.
We, here on earth live
in an environment
where plasma is actually rare,
but in fact, through the universe.
All of the visible material
that we see is mostly plasma.
Plasma is the predominant form
of matter in the universe,
visible matter that we see.
That's not getting into the kind
of crazy stuff like dark matter.
But the visible matter that we see.
Stars and nebulas and
galaxies and all that.
It's all plasma.
And that's what the
sun is made up of.
And the cool thing about plasma,
it acts like a liquid in a gas,
but it's electromagnetic.
It responds to electricity
and magnetism.
And that's really a
key feature to it.
And here it acts as a tracer
for these magnetic fields.
Let's look at slightly
cooler temperature.
Slightly lower down
in the atmosphere.
This is about 100,000.
Somewhere between 40
to 100,000 degrees.
And, here, you're seeing something
similar to those loops that you saw.
But what you're seeing here is
material that's being supported
above the surface of the
sun by magnetic fields.
So, if you remember back
when I mentioned during
that total solar eclipse at the
very top there's this little stuff
sticking out.
And I said actually it's really
red, it's kind of hard to see.
This is the material.
That's actually why they
choose to color this red.
This is a false color, but
this is the same material shown
in a different wavelength.
And it is in fact red
in visible light.
It's called a prominence.
And that's something you can see
during a total solar eclipse,
but now you can also see when
you look at the sun from space.
Again, here is a sunspot and you see
there are these little tiny loops
they are connecting the sunspots.
So, I won't go into to a detail but
the thing to think about sunspots,
now if you're at all familiar
with the idea of a bar magnet.
Okay if you've ever seen a
bar magnet, or even seen,
maybe in a class where you take
a bar magnet and you put it next
to some iron filing, and it sort of
traces out these invisible lines.
That's really what's happening
when you saw those loops.
Same sort of principle.
And a magnet, like a
bar magnet is a type
of magnet that's a
very simple structure,
and it has a positive or a negative.
It has a north or a south, depending
on how you want to label it.
And so, the magnetic field lines
go from one pole plus or north
to the other pole, minus or south.
And the earth is the same way.
You can think of the earth
as a sort of a bar magnet.
It has a north pole and a south
pole, that's where it spins.
But it also has a magnetic pole.
And so, the magnetic field lines
go from one pole to the other.
They connect them.
And that's why you see these loops.
Because the sunspots
are actually connected.
One sunspot has a magnetic
field line that's going
to another sunspot.
And they're almost like
bar magnets on the side.
So, on the surface you'll see, you
know magnetic fields do like this,
they make these loops that
you see coming out of the sun.
And the reason that I wanted to
bring that up, is that is the driver
of all of this energy that's
coming away from the sun.
It's magnetic fields.
I'm going to show you
a cartoon animation
to give you some more
detail what's happening.
But magnetic fields are
kind of like rubber bands.
They have tension,
they have pressure.
You take a rubber band you
take it, twist it, twist it,
twist it it's going
to start to knot up.
I actually used to give the analogy
of phone cords, but
then nobody knows.
At a certain age, nobody knows
what a phone cord is anymore.
But we all remember when
we had long phone cords
and over time they
would get all knotted up
and become very difficult.
Well that's actually a
similar sort of thing.
So, these magnetic fields on
the sun are getting all twisted.
So, when you saw the sunspots
moving across the sun, as they move,
they actually get all
twisted and knotted up.
And if they get knotted up
enough, if you take rubber band
and you twist it, and twist it,
and twist it eventually
it's going to pop.
That energy's got to go somewhere.
It can only hold so much.
Magnetic fields are very
similar in that way.
As they get twisted and they
build up energy at some point
that energy's got to go somewhere.
And what happens?
That energy is released explosively.
And bam. You see the solar
flare and you see all
that material come flying away.
So, that's what's happening when
we have those eruptions on the sun.
They're releasing this magnetic
energy that's getting built
up as the magnetic fields are
getting all twisted and knotted.
So, I love this this little, this
actually got cut off because I had
to change the aspect
ratio of the talk,
but I love this little cartoon.
Basically, it says, an increase
in sunspots is an indicator
of potentially dangerous
solar activity.
And at the very end the
guy looks at it and says,
I don't like the looks of this.
So, it's actually not
so far from the truth.
As you start to see more
sunspots, bigger sunspots,
very complicated sunspots, that
means they have more energy built
up inside of them and
more potential to explode.
And in fact, we see the number of
sunspots over time goes up and down.
Goes from very low number of
sunspots, to high number back
down to low, roughly
every 11 years from low,
high to low is roughly
every 11 years.
Sometimes it's shorter,
maybe 10 and a half, 10.
Sometimes it's a little bit longer.
But that's called the solar cycle.
Solar activity cycle.
And people have been
watching sunspots
since the mid to early 1700s.
Actually, they've been watching
them much longer than that.
They've been watching them for
hundreds, potentially thousands
of years, but we've
been recording them.
In Europe, they started recording
them back in the early 1700s.
And, though the data got better over
time, they did a pretty good job
and they kept really decent records.
We can go back and we
see this up and down.
We see some peaks are higher, you
know one solar cycle may be higher
than the next one,
a little bit lower.
Some are a little bit
longer, a little bit shorter.
As a matter of fact, right
now, we're in what we call,
since we started numbering
them, we're in cycle 24.
And we're coming down off the peak.
Somewhere around 2012, 2013 was
the peak of the current cycle, 24.
And this cycle turns out to be
the smallest cycle in 100 years.
So, it's a relatively small cycle.
But we still see solar activity.
It's just compared
to the previous one.
And they go up and down.
Sometimes we see a big
one and another big one,
and another big one, and then
a little bit smaller one.
We don't really have a good handle
of what pattern exists there.
You're going to hear in the news
every so often somebody's going
to say, we're going to go into
this next great solar minimum
and everything's going to freeze up
and you know the sun
is doing this and that.
Well, the reality is they
don't really know what they're
talking about.
Because nobody knows.
Because the sun's been doing
this for billions of years.
And we've only been watching it
for a couple hundred years
in that kind of detail.
So, there's no way we can truly
understand what that pattern is yet.
We get a little bit
of a handle on it
and we start trying to
put some physics in.
But we really don't
understand that too well.
Now, I'm going to show you a couple
of quick examples of sunspots.
This is zooming in with a very
high resolution telescope.
Happened to be one that I worked
for in Japan called Hinoday.
And just to give you some size
scale again, so those little dimples
that you see wiggling,
okay that's real.
Turns out that the energy from
inside the sun moves to the surface
and when it gets close
to the surface it actually does
what's called a convection cell,
just like boiling water.
The energy rises to the surface,
releases, cool back down.
And it makes these, what we call
convection cells, these bubbles.
So, you see those little wiggles.
Those are real.
And they're all about the size of
Texas just to give you some scale.
So, that's a sunspot.
You saw this flash there, there
was actually a visible flash.
That actually is an indication
it was a very strong solar flare.
We don't generally see solar
flares very well in visible light.
This is visible light.
So, when you see that flash over it,
that actually means it's pretty big.
Here's another idea of
the scale of sunspots.
Again, you see these
sunspots are very complicated.
They're messy.
And that's actually an indication
that the there's energy
stored up in them.
When you see a nice simple
round sunspot, it's boring.
There's really not much to it.
It means there's not
a lot of energy.
But as they start to get
elongated and get kind of gnarly
and broken up, that's
actually a sin of complexity
and that means there's energy there.
Now, I mentioned that one of
the keys is magnetic fields.
But there's another key about the
energy that's stored up in the sun
and what creates the dynamics
that makes space weather.
And it's something, I'm going
to show you a cartoon animation,
but it's something called
differential rotation.
So, think for a second about planets
like Jupiter, Saturn,
the gas giants.
Okay. These are not solid planets.
When they rotate, they rotate faster
as they get towards the
equator they rotate faster.
As you move towards the
poles they rotate slower.
That's why you see
those bands for example.
Because they're not solid.
Well, the sun is not solid.
The sun is a plasma as I mentioned.
And so, that means that it doesn't
rotate at the same rate when you're
at the equator versus the poles.
So, it's a plasma.
Plasma are attracted to
electricity and magnetism.
So, what happens is it means
that when this plasma moves,
it drags magnetic fields with it.
Okay. So, they're connected.
They're coupled to each other.
Now the sun, in its
simplest state is also
like the earth, like
a giant bar magnet.
So, it has magnetic fields
that go from north to south,
south to north through it.
And so, they're kind of this way.
Now, watch this little animation.
So, you see the magnetic fields
are going to start off up and down.
But the equator's moving faster.
And plasma drags the magnetic field.
So, it drags the middle part faster.
So, inside the sun, the magnetic
fields are getting all twisted up.
So, this is, you're
actually looking inside.
So, you see how they get all knotted
and they start popping
through the surface?
That's the sunspots.
That's where the sunspots are.
The magnetic fields
are getting twisted up.
They're rising up from
underneath, and they're popping
through the visible surface,
and that's the sunspot.
So, I'm going to show
you another animation
from a different perspective to
show you what I'm talking about.
See if this will go.
Come on. Well it's
supposed to, there we go.
Okay. So, there are the sunspots
and the magnetic fields
coming through it.
So, from underneath,
the magnetic fields
that have gotten twisted start
popping through the surface.
And where they pop
through, they suppress heat.
So, that means that they look dark.
They're not actually dark,
but they're dark compared
to what's around them.
And then eventually you
see that it gets so knotted
that they flash their
releasing energy.
That flash was the solar flare,
and then you saw this little blob
of stuff coming off the top,
that's the coronal mass ejection.
So, I'll let this run
through one more time.
So, they're popping through.
They're getting pushed together.
And then all the sudden,
there goes a piece of it
and solar material flying away.
Okay, so that's an animation
of these complex eruptions.
So, here's sort of a static graphic.
Now, for the moment ignore the
earth, of course this is not
to scale, but ignore
the earth on the right.
But what I want you to see is
again, these are the three parts.
So, there's actually a flash here,
there's a bright and
that's the flare.
All of this stuff here is the
CME, the coronal mass ejection.
But remember it's pushing
stuff in front of it.
It's actually creating what's
called a shock, shock wave.
Just like a sonic boom when
an aircraft travels faster
than the speed of sound, it actually
creates this shock in front of it,
that actually makes
the noise the boom.
There's a shock here.
So, here is the shock wave in front.
And those are those
particles that I mentioned.
And I'm going to show you what
those particles actually look
like shortly.
But those are again, the sort
of three parts of space weather.
The flare, the release
of light, the stuff,
the material and magnetic field.
The coronal mass ejection, and then
all the things that plows ahead
of it, the things that pushes ahead
of it, which are these particles.
So, the sun is always
spinning stuff out.
It has these big explosions,
but also there is a constant
stream of solar particles.
So, as I mentioned, as you move
up in the solar atmosphere
it's getting hotter and hotter
and it is literally boiling off,
it is escape, so much energy
that material from the
sun escapes into space.
And it is streaming away
from the sun all the time.
And it fills the entire
solar system.
It's called the solar wind.
So, there's sort of this
background material that's always
streaming away.
And these big explosions are
like waves on top of the ocean.
You know the ocean is sort
of this background ocean
that's always there.
And then you have these
huge explosions
which are releasing additional
material on top of that.
Kind of riding on top of this solar
wind that's always moving away
from the sun.
So, that solar wind is always
moving away, sort of ebb and flow.
And we see that in our
entire solar system.
In fact, all of that
material streams
out way past the farthest
planets in the solar system
and creates this bubble around the
solar system called the heliosphere.
It's kind of the realm
of influence of the sun.
And here's a little animation
of what that looks like.
So, you see the solar system is
actually kind of small in there.
There's this big bubble.
There are all these particles
streaming away from the sun.
And as solar activity
goes up and down,
that bubble expands and contracts.
So, this, expansion and contraction
is on the order of years.
It's moving out, coming back in.
And the reason you see this sort
of elongated thing here so is
because this whole structure,
the whole solar system,
is traveling through the galaxy.
And so, you can think of it like
a ship traveling through water
and it leaves this wake around it.
And as a matter of fact, we've
looked at other start systems
with the Hubble Space Telescope
and we see this exact thing,
we call those astrospheres.
We see this kind of teardrop
structure that's the bubble
of a star traveling
through the galaxy.
That's why it's not just a perfect
circle you see this stuff coming
out this way.
We're going to see the
same effect with the earth.
The earth actually
has the similar sort
of structure called the
magnetosphere, as it's travelling
through the solar system
and I'm going
to show you what that looks like.
But the key here is really
that space is not empty.
We're living inside
of this environment
that fills the whole solar
system, that's created by the sun.
See there was an explosion there.
Now, we're moving away.
There's the solar wind, these
particles that are always there.
But then there was an
explosion and there's going
to be this blast of material.
It's like driving into
a blinding rainstorm.
Now, these particles you're seeing
this visualization is actually based
on real data.
This is not an animation;
this is real data.
So, there's the blob of stuff
that is the coronal mass
ejection, traveling through space.
Now, it's about to hit Venus.
So, those particles, the CME,
coronal mass ejection also
with magnetic field,
is hitting Venus.
Now, notice it's sort of
hitting Venus directly on.
And I'm going to go
back to that point.
Now, we're getting to the earth.
Now, notice the particles.
They're kind of moving
around the earth.
See, some of them are kind of
deflected here, above and below.
And the reason is because the
earth has a magnetic field.
Venus does not have
a magnetic field.
And that's why the particles
were hitting Venus directly.
Because these particles, this stuff
from the sun is electromagnetic
in nature.
It response to electricity
and magnetism.
So, the earth's magnetic
field is deflecting that.
And actually, I don't, there's a
cool animation and I don't want
to go into it, but I was
supposed to cut that off.
But, what I wanted to just point
out is the earth has a magnetic
field, just like the sun does.
It's kind of a bar magnet.
It's a little more complicated.
So, all of this stuff coming
off the sun is interacting
with the earth's magnetic field.
In this case, deflected by it.
And it actually creates
this similar kind
of tear-dropped stretched bubble
structure that I was talking to you
about for the heliosphere.
And we call that the magnetosphere.
And so, what happens when
all that stuff interacts
with the earth's magnetic field?
You get this.
You get all of this stuff.
This is the Aurora.
Sometimes called the
Northern or Southern Lights.
In this case, we're actually
looking at the Southern Lights
because this is the International
Space Station traveling
over the Indian Ocean.
But you see all of that
crazy dynamic structure.
That's because there are
particles interacting
with the earth's magnetic field.
In fact, those particles are
hitting the atmosphere of the earth.
They're hitting oxygen and nitrogen.
And they're exciting those
elements and causing them to glow
in greens, blues, sometimes red.
So, it depends on which element.
It also depends on
how high up they are.
So, what's really happening there?
Okay what's happening?
So, I mentioned that the
earth has a magnetic field.
It's kind of like a bar magnet,
but it's a little more
complicated than that.
But remember, all this
stuff is coming off the sun.
It's interacting with
the magnetic field
and it stretches the
earth's magnetic field
from this kind spherical structure
into this long elongated thing.
So, I'm going to show you
another computer visualization.
This is real data connected
with a computer model showing
the magnetic field of the earth.
To show you what's happening.
So, we're looking from the side.
So, you see in this case, the sun
is actually over here to the left.
So, there's stuff traveling,
hitting, you see that it starts off,
it's almost kind of a
little bit more symmetric.
But it's dragging it
all out this way.
But when you see that blast that's
hitting and pulling everything,
that's the coronal mass ejection.
That's the CME that billions
of tons of material slamming
into the earth's magnetosphere.
Now, this case we're actually
looking at data that was taken
from an event that went off to the
side of the sun, because it was one
of the largest events we'd ever
seen and we're projecting it
onto the earth to see
what would actually happen
if that event hit the earth.
So, this is an event that didn't in
fact hit the earth, but if it had,
we wanted to see what would happen.
So, notice here, right about here is
where satellites in lower orbit sit.
And you see they sit inside the
magnetic field until that thing hits
and pushes it all and all
the sudden, spacecraft,
which were sitting inside the
magnetic field are now outside the
magnetic field.
Because all this stuff
coming off the sun pushes it
and is pushing the atmosphere
and the magnetic structure
of the earth, away from the sun.
So, this is a very extreme event.
So, let me show you a real
example of space weather, okay?
March 7, 2012.
Keep an eye right there.
There was a flare, here it is again.
There's actually two flares.
One, and two.
You see all that stuff moving?
That's material being blasted away.
You can see the magnetic
fields are actually wiggling.
Those loops are actually wiggling.
So, that is, the flare is that flash
of light and it is throwing away,
it's spitting, the sun is spitting
out billions of tons of material.
Now, it's very difficult to
see that from this perspective,
to see that material
leaving the sun.
So, what do we do?
We actually create an
artificial eclipse.
So, we take a telescope that
looks at the sun in white light,
in visible light, and we put a disk
in front of the telescope to block
out the bright disk of the sun.
Because what's happening
during an eclipse?
The disk of the sun is
a million times brighter
than that wispy structure you
saw during a total solar eclipse.
So, when the moon blocks the disk
of the sun out, it's allowing us
to see things that are a million
times fainter than the surface.
It's just like looking
at a bright light.
If there's a little dim light
next to it, you're not going
to see it unless you put
your hand up in front
and sort of block it out.
So, we're going to do that.
Now, the sun is actually
in this little circle here.
The reason being, we
can't an eclipse as good
as the moon and the sun system can.
So, we can't get the
eclipse to block all the way
down to the surface of the sun.
So, that's why this
disk blocking the sun
out is exactly much
bigger than the sun.
But, you'll see there's a
wispy structure that came.
There's this kind of
smoke ring like thing.
That's the coronal mass
ejection, or the CME,
but then remember that's pushing
all this stuff in front of it.
Particles; super, super high-energy
particles traveling close
to the speed of light.
Well you see all the snow, that's
the particles hitting the camera.
Hitting the CCD.
This camera has a CCD which
is almost identical to what's
in your cellphone, or
your digital camera.
And when those high-energy
particles travel
through that CCD they
leave these little tracks
because they're depositing energy.
And so, that's the
snow you're seeing.
So, this is actually
a really big event.
That's a lot of snow.
That's a very, very
huge particle event.
Now, why do we care about that?
If you're an astronaut in
space, those particles,
that's a blast of radiation.
When you're on earth, we
are very well protected
by not just the magnetic
field of the earth,
but actually more importantly,
the atmosphere.
We live in a very thick atmosphere.
It doesn't feel very
thick, but there's a lot
of atmosphere between us and space.
And it stops all of those particles.
Unless you're on top of a mountain,
or traveling in an airplane,
you can't really measure much
of these types of particles.
They don't make it to the ground.
But if you're an astronaut
and if you're out in the ISS
or even traveling to the moon,
then you're no longer protected.
And even worse if you're
traveling to Mars.
The moon is even sometimes protected
by the magnetic field of the earth.
Because sometimes the
moon actually orbits
in the magnetic field of the earth.
So, it just so happens that in 1972
between the last two Apollo
missions, there was a solar storm
that produced the largest particle
event, particle storm like this,
all this snow that
we've ever recorded.
So, if either of those
Apollo missions had,
if the second to last one
had gone a little bit later,
or the last one had gone
a little bit earlier,
on a scale of about a month,
astronauts would have been traveling
to the moon and a storm 10 times or
more than this would have hit them.
And they probably would've gotten
a lethal dose of radiation.
Because they're not
particularly protected
in literally the tin can they
were flying in to the moon.
So, that's a really critical aspect.
And that is one of the biggest
challenges of traveling to,
especially to some place like Mars.
Now, when you go to Mars, Mars
doesn't have the magnetic field,
but it also has an
extremely thin atmosphere.
To put that in perspective, the
atmosphere of Mars is about as thick
as our atmosphere at 100,000 feet.
Higher than any of the
commercial airplanes flying.
You know you've see
the movie "The Martian"
which is actually pretty good.
There's a lot that's
really quite accurate in it.
But one thing that's not
accurate in it is the storm.
You could barely blow
a tissue over with Mars
because the atmosphere is so thin.
There's just, there's
no pressure there,
much less a spaceship or a rocket.
But, because there is no atmosphere,
that means you're almost
unprotected from these particles.
So, that would mean you need
to build your enclosure
either underground,
or you have to have materials
that are thick enough
to protect you from it.
So, this is one of the biggest
challenges of traveling in space.
The environment is quite harsh
and the biggest issue
are these particles.
I'm going to talk a little bit more
about some of the other types of
and aspect of space weather,
in particular how it
impacts our technology.
But in terms of flying
through the solar system,
these particle events are really the
most critical part of space weather
that we have to pay attention to.
And this is the biggest challenge
that we have going
to a place like Mars.
And for the moon also, it's
still a huge challenge.
But especially Mars.
Because really it's
the long-term exposure
to radiation that is an issue.
Now one of the things,
I'm not going to go into,
but there is another aspect to it.
We are also, our solar system
is filled with particles
from outside the solar
system called cosmic rays.
So, huge explosions that happen
around the galaxy called
supernova; stars exploding.
They treated particles even
more energetic than this.
They're incredibly
powerful explosions.
And so, those particles are
everywhere and they actually make it
into the solar system through
the magnetic field of the sun.
But they are somewhat
deflected by that.
So, when the sun is really active,
these cosmic rays are
actually less of them.
The sun actually pushes so when
that heliosphere I
showed you pushes outward,
it actually pushes these cosmic rays
out and away from the solar system.
And as the sun gets quieter,
and that heliosphere shrinks,
more cosmic rays get in.
So, when solar activity is
low, cosmic rays are high.
And we actually see, if you look
at the sunspots, and cosmic rays,
they're exactly opposite each other.
So, that's the other challenge.
That I'm not going to talk
about in any detail here,
but that's the other
part of traveling.
It actually may turn
out, strangely enough
that traveling during high
solar activity may be better
in the long run.
Because it's really the long-term
exposure that's the issue.
But, these are still a problem.
The other part of this, you see
all those particles are hitting the
telescope and leaving
all this snow in there.
Well, those particles also do the
same kind of thing to electronics.
They're traveling through memory.
So, one of the biggest issues is
when one of those particles travels
through a piece of
memory, solid-state memory.
So, remember we work in what's
called binary; zeros and ones.
All of our computers are using
zeros and ones to carry information.
And if one of those
particles travels through,
if it has enough energy,
it can actually flip.
Turn a zero into a one,
or a one into a zero.
You've got a whole bunch of
those, they make up an instruction
that tells the telescope,
take a picture.
Stay on. Turn off.
Or tells the spacecraft,
keep going forward.
Go to the left, go to the right.
There are all these commands
inside the computer that are made
up of these zeros and ones.
You've got this command and all of
the sudden a zero changes to a one.
The spacecraft has all the sudden
been told, oh turn off your engines.
You know, shut off life
support, or something like that.
I mean. So fortunately,
it's not quite,
it's a little more
complicated that than.
But that is a problem.
So, this is the other
challenge when we go
out into this harsh environment,
is that we have to deal with this.
And so, we have to do
all kinds of things,
like use software to
make corrections.
But when there's a really big storm,
one of the things we have to do
for our spacecraft, is we
actually turn them off.
We basically put them
in a safe mode.
It's sort of like, there's
a thunderstorm coming,
there's lightening, so you unplug
your stereo, or your TV so that
if lightening hits it
doesn't kind of overload it.
We sort of do something
similar to that.
Basically, we put them
in a safe mode
so that these things
don't have an impact.
Here's another example, this is just
another corona graph showing you
slightly different perspective.
Actually, there's a slight, you'll
see the sun actually disappear.
So, I've actually overlaid
an image of the sun
on top of the chronograph.
There actually is an
eclipse of the moon.
And you can see if you look
at it closely you see the disk
in the center all the sudden
gets black for a second.
If you blink, you'll miss it.
And this is one of the
impacts of that storm.
We had an amazing Aurora, all
over the northern US,
Michigan, Scandinavia.
So, this incredible Aurora.
But I'm going to show you
really quickly what are some
of the thing we have to think
about for space weather.
So, remember that all of
this stuff is happening,
because again it's electromagnetic.
All of that material is
plasma, which response
to electricity and magnetism.
And it's carrying magnetic
fields with it.
So, all of the phenomena
that we're talking
about is electromagnetic in nature.
And so, what does that mean?
That means that it
impacts technology.
So, a couple of things happen.
So, I mentioned those particles.
The flare and the CME create those
high-energy particles you saw
on the camera.
Those impact spacecraft,
they can damage electronics.
There should be an astronaut
floating around up here
who would also be in danger.
The other thing is that when you
saw that model of the magnetosphere
and this big blast hit it, and
it starts wiggling like this
and everything starts moving.
Magnetic fields when
they move quickly,
they create electrical currents.
That's the physics behind
generators and motors.
You're moving a magnetic field very
quickly it generates electricity.
Well, that happens in the
outer atmosphere of the earth.
So, there are currents
that are generated up here.
Now, those currents
also give us the Aurora.
They help to create, and
accelerate the particles
and give us the Aurora.
But, it impacts communications.
It's disrupts GPS.
It doesn't necessarily stop GPS,
but it makes it less accurate.
So, if your GPS is telling
you something is right here,
the accuracy could be 10 times worse
and it could actually be
you know a couple of meters,
or even a couple of kilometers away.
That may not be as big a deal for
us, but these days we have farming
that uses automated tractors
that are running on GPS.
We even have, this is crazy.
I talked to a friend of
mine who drives trucks.
We even have people who drive
trucks around dangerous mountains
in bad weather using GPS.
But we drill in the ocean
for oil, or things like that.
Doing even complicated construction
we use GPS for where things are.
So, that's a huge issue.
It impacts communications
on airplanes.
One of the issues is airplanes can't
be out of contact for less than,
somewhere on the scale of minutes,
when it's talking to
various airports.
These storms, these occurrence,
they're generated closer
to the poles.
So, the magnetic fields
go from pole to pole.
So, they go like this in this loop.
When they come into the
North Pole or the South Pole,
that's where the magnetic
field is weakest.
And that's where the
storms are the strongest.
That's why we see Aurora mostly
near the North and South Pole.
As a storm becomes stronger, we
see these Aurora move farther
and farther, closer to the equator.
The storms are actually
moving down the equator.
That's what's happening.
But if you're in an airplane
and you're traveling from DC
to Hong Kong you want to
travel over the poles.
That's the shortest distance,
but you can travel over the poles
if the communications are
out because of a solar storm.
So, they have to travel
around instead,
which means that they spend
a lot more fuel and a lot
of money, and a lot more time.
So, that's an issue for them.
Also, if you're traveling as a
pilot or an airline attendant
for long periods of time
over, you know many years,
you are exposed to more radiation.
Because you're higher up.
So, that's an issue too.
They don't want people
to be traveling
through the poles during a storm.
One of those particle storms.
And then one of the other issues
is these currents are generated
up in the atmosphere.
They're also generated
down on the ground.
Because when currents run
near a transmission line,
okay near a conductor.
In this case, let's say
between two electrical poles
that are a kilometer apart.
That's a long transmission line.
That actually picks
up those currents
and currents are generated in that.
If those currents are strong enough,
and this is actually
much more analogous
to the storm hitting your house.
Those currents can
overload transformers,
and they can take out power grids.
And we've seen this happen,
1989 we had the entire
Quebec power grid went out.
And there have been other
storms that have hit.
Generally, mostly communities in
places like a Sweden or Norway
or something like that because
they're close to the poles.
But, if they're strong enough,
they can reach farther south,
and they can impact us.
So, that's another area that
we have to be concerned on.
Now, one thing to think about is
that the good thing is that all
of these industries
are well aware of this.
So, they pay close attention
to the weather report
when it comes to space weather.
And they take certain actions.
As I said, they reroute planes,
or they may change transformer
settings and things like that.
So, it's something that they
do pay close attention to.
Now, I'm going to quickly go through
a few things just to show you.
So, what do we do to keep an eye
on the space weather,
how do we do this?
How do we keep an eye on that?
Well, it turns out we have
a huge fleet of spacecraft.
We have 18 missions
just in heliophysics,
the study of the sun and its impact.
Just in heliophysics we have
18 missions that study all
of these different aspects of what
comes off the sun, what's traveling
through space, and
what reaches earth.
But as I mentioned for
NASA, we're also interested
in all the other planets.
So, we put instruments
on even things like Juno,
which has just reached
Jupiter, or New Horizon,
which recently, last
year passed Pluto.
All of them measure space weather
phenomenon as they're traveling
through the solar system.
Now, this is just the spacecraft
that are around the earth.
This elongated structure
is the magnetosphere.
So, again, the sun is now over here.
And it's pulling this
big long structure back.
But these are all of the
different spacecraft that we have
that are looking at that.
When we have all that
data, we actually make; so,
here's just an example, there's
a big storm that we measured.
This actually went off
the side of the sun
because we have spacecraft
around the sun.
We have spacecraft on the
backside of the sun and we're able
to see things that happen
everywhere on the sun,
not just stuff that goes to earth.
So, you can see, this
was a really big event.
See how much snow there was there.
This was the biggest event ever
recorded with modern spacecraft.
And so, we actually put that into
a computer model with real physics.
And just like we have
a hurricane tracking,
just like we track hurricanes to
figure out where are they going to,
you know how far are they going
to be, where are they going
to make landfall, when are
they going to make landfall.
We do the same thing
with solar storms.
So, there's one, there's the earth.
There's the sun.
Now, wait for it.
There's the one you just saw.
It travelled off this way.
So, there's a couple
of smaller ones.
There's Mars.
That was the spacecraft
stereo, there's a stereo here
and a stereo here that are
actually seeing the sun,
not just from head on.
So, just to let you
know our generation,
all of us are the first humans to be
able to see the entire sun at once.
Because we have spacecraft
everywhere, we actually see the sun.
All of it at one time.
We don't just see the
part that's facing us.
And that's the first time
that's ever happened.
And so, as I mentioned, we
use space weather forecasting
for all the way out to Pluto.
So, here's New Horizon.
So, when the New Horizon Mission
was getting close to Pluto,
they contacted the NASA space
weather forecasters and said,
all right we want you
to give us six months
of all the stuff that's
coming off the sun,
so we know what we
should expect out here.
Because we have instruments,
but we have no idea.
So, it's like being somewhere
and actually having rain gages
and things like that on your
car, but you don't actually have,
you don't actually have the
Weather Channel and the radar maps
to know what's happening
where you are.
So, you call somebody
and you say, hey,
can you tell me what it's
going to be like where I am.
And so, that's what they did.
And so, we make these kinds
of forecasts that are just
like a hurricane forecast
for the entire solar system,
to know what's happening everywhere.
So, I want to end, this is
actually a kind of a cool,
this is just to show you;
it's a little bit hard to see,
it's kind of dim but just to show
you how dynamic the Aurora is.
So, this is on a scale
of tens of minutes.
So, it's moving pretty fast.
But I want to end with
one last thing.
So, I hope everyone gets a
chance to experience this.
Next year, 2017, August 21st there
will be a total solar eclipse.
And that path of totality,
which is about 60 miles wide,
is going to start here in Oregon and
travel down through South Carolina.
Now, we're going to be over here,
we're going to see about 85%
of a partial eclipse, 85%
of the sun will be covered.
But, this is the first time
we've had a total solar eclipse
since the late seventies in the US.
It's first time we've
had one that's gone
across the entire US
since the early 1900s.
the next time this will happen
that it's going to go all the way
across the US will be 2045.
We will have another total solar
eclipse that's going to start here
and move like this in 2024.
We are not going to get totality.
We're again going to
be really close.
But it will be easier for us.
It's going to go like this I think.
So, you can drive just up in
Northern Pennsylvania I think.
The interesting thing is that
this totality in 2024 passes
over the one that's
happening next year.
But I highly recommend,
if you can take the time
to travel somewhere along this line
because you will not
be disappointed.
So, if you want more
information about this,
go to eclipse2017.nasa.gov.
But this is a really
spectacular event.
And I hope everyone
gets to participate.
And even if you can't go, there
are going to be broadcasts
from numerous folks, including NASA,
but also for example
Exploratorium in San Francisco.
Other organizations are going to
have live broadcasts and webcasts
from all over the country.
Now, anywhere along here
you will see totality
for just over two minutes.
Roughly about two and
a half minutes.
Which doesn't seem like that long,
but it actually is pretty long.
It will be almost like night.
It's an amazing experience.
So, I hope everybody gets a chance
to take a look and try it out.
So, at this point, I want to
end it and open up the floor
for questions [applause].
>> STEPHANIE MARCUS: Well, first
of all [inaudible] thank
you very much Dr. Jones.
And what's your questions?
We could go on and on.
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: So,
in the very back
of the room a gentleman
had a question.
>> Two questions.
[Inaudible] and one more abstract.
[Inaudible] question how do you
specifically define the word field,
f-i-e-l-d.
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: How do you
specifically define field
in physics okay.
>> Second question, what
is a Wolf-Rayet star.
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: What is
a Wolf-Rayet star, okay.
Okay. Well, a field is
something that, let's see.
That's a tough one.
It describes.
Yeah, a field describes some
phenomenon that is continuous.
That is, it has every point
you can pick any point
and that field describes
the strength
of this phenomenon at that point.
Like magnetic field, electric field.
So, but it is a continuous structure
that defines some sort
of force or quantity.
Flow of fluid something like that.
Wolf-Rayet star is, my
astronomy's a little rusty on this.
I believe a Wolf-Rayet
star is a young,
a very, very young active star.
But I honestly don't remember
I'd have to look it up.
I'm a little rusty
on my star physics.
>> I'm familiar with Wolf-Rayet 104.
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: Well,
that's from "Star Trek."
>> STEPHANIE MARCUS: Let's
give somebody else a chance.
You can come up later and
ask a few more questions.
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: Okay.
Go ahead.
>> About what time of day will this
solar eclipse happen on August 21st?
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: Yeah so it starts,
let's see on the west coast
it starts around 10:30.
You know what I've got little
thing here, a little brochure
that actually has the
details, let me pull it out.
So, let's see well
central time for example
in Alabama, it's around noon.
So, it's going to be just at
about 1:30 I think around here.
Yeah. So, it's going to go
on for several hours starting
over on the west coast.
But if you go
to eclipse2017.nasa.gov you can
get more details about that.
And we have these maps too, so.
Yes, sir?
>> In terms of the
effects on astronauts
who are outside of [inaudible].
I know there's been specific
studies on the astronauts
in the Space Station for long
periods as to the effects of gravity
and you know biological type.
Have there been any actual studies
of the effects of the space litter
in general or the increased
radiation on them.
Have there been any increased
incidence of cancer or?
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: There have.
Well, all of the astronauts, for
example wear radiation badges.
Because they're basically
considered radiation workers.
Just like many airline workers
are considered radiation workers.
So, they do monitor that.
They do have various
kinds of equipment
to monitor, as a proxy for humans.
I don't know what the long-term
studies are on ISS astronauts.
But I do know that there have been
a lot of studies recently related
to Apollo astronauts
and they do have,
it's my understanding there's
statistically significant increase
in cancer and impact
amongst Apollo astronauts.
And they of course were exposed to
the most radiation, more so than ISS
because ISS still gets some of
the magnetic field protection.
And the materials are better now.
But I do know this is an
active area of research.
And there's a group for example
at Johnson Space Center in Houston
that actively works with
the NASA forecasters,
but they study the impacts
specifically for our astronauts.
>> Just as a quick follow up,
if you look at that effect
and the gravity effects and
all the rest, does it make you
as a NASA scientist, does it
make you wonder if we talk
about increasing man flights or
starting man flights to Mars,
if this is really a feasible idea?
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: It does.
I mean I'm not an expert on
it, so I certainly don't speak
from a NASA point of view.
But, yeah it worries me.
I mean it is a huge, huge issue.
We do know that you know astronauts
experience anywhere from ten
to more times the normal
radiation levels.
I mean everybody experiences
radiation all the time.
And that's there's normal
background radiation.
But astronauts certainly
get significantly higher,
and they know that.
They're well aware of that.
But yeah, it's going to be really,
really harsh on a nine-month journey
to Mars with cosmic rays, not
even necessarily the solar aspect,
but just the continuous
amount of cosmic rays.
Because again, these sorts
of things, we're not really,
the issues is not as much
acute, short-term huge impacts,
which is certainly still a problem.
It's really that long term
because the way radiation is
measured is your cumulative dose
over time.
Because the same thing with
pilots and with astronauts.
They have a limit as to how
much radiation they can get.
And they will be grounded,
and many have been grounded,
after they have reached
that threshold.
So, they're going to have to
change those thresholds for Mars
because it's going to
be much, much different.
Yes, sir?
>> Given the current measurements
of solar activity at the surface
of the sun, is it possible
to predict solar flares,
and if so how far in
advance and with what kind
of [inaudible] resolution?
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: Okay, so the
question is basically are we able
to predict solar flares
and with what kind
of for resolution,
timescale resolution.
That's a great question.
That's a really, really,
really hard problem.
Right now, we are only able
to forecast solar flares
on a statistical basis,
about the same
as how we forecast
precipitation percentages.
So, the way right now precipitation,
when you see 80% is that they look
at equivalent conditions in the
same location over a certain amount
of time and say 8 out of 10 times
when the day was like
today, it rained.
So, there's 80% chance
it's going to rain.
And that's really about the best
we can do with solar flares.
We look at the sunspots and
the structure of the sunspots,
and the magnetic field strengths.
And we look at that particular
type of sunspot configuration.
And we look at past examples of
that over multiple solar cycles
and we say, well 8 out of 10 times
we say this particular shaped
sunspot with this magnificent
field configuration and it produced
so many flares of a certain size.
And that's the way the
percentages are done.
So, that's a really, it's not a
really very strongly way to do it.
Because we're not able to currently
do it based on the physics.
I mean ideally that's what
you want to be able to do.
You want to really be able to
look at the physics and say,
we measured these physical
parameters
and we can give you some
sort of robust estimate
of what's the probability
of a flare.
Right now, for example, the best
measure of whether we're going
to have a flare is if
we've already had one.
Yeah. So, it is a tough problem.
And unfortunately, I don't
really have a very good answer
because there isn't one.
Yeah. Yes, ma'am.
>> Is it possible that we can
feel the sunspot explosion?
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: As far as
we've been able, now you will see
in different types of
literature and folks will say,
well you know I'm affected by
solar activity blah, blah, blah.
As far as we can tell no.
No. because one of the
things is we are, again,
fortunately very well protected
by our atmosphere and
our magnetic field.
The thing about physics when
you talk about impacts, I mean,
honestly almost everything
affects everything else
to some degree, but how much.
And is it at all significant.
And that's really the
way physics works.
I mean if I have a magnet across
that room, like a small bar magnet,
there is a measurable, there
is a magnetic field here
from that magnet across the room.
But it may, it will be
extremely, extremely weak.
And probably I will not
be able to measure it.
But I can tell you based on
what I know about physics,
there is a magnetic field here from
that magnetic field across the room.
But, there's also magnetic
fields from everything else
around me that's being produced
that are probably significantly
stronger than that.
And so, more than likely, even
though there is a field here,
it really isn't affecting me.
Not in any sort of measurable way.
And this is the same sort of
thing with space weather impact.
And as space weather becomes sort of
more popular and in the public eye,
I do hear a lot more about that,
about the impact to all sorts
of physical aspects and there
just really is no evidence
that that's the case.
I would be much more worried about
you know walking by a hospital
with an MRI machine than I
would about the sun in terms
of magnetic fields and
that sort of stuff.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Has anybody ever
worked at NASA if they have
to reignite the sun if it went out?
>> C. ALEX YOUNG: Oh,
that's a cool question.
So, has anyone ever worked to if
they have to reignite the sun.
I don't know.
I mean I certainly, being a
science fiction fan have seen lots
of cool stuff about that.
I don't know if anybody would
think about it too much,
because I think most people would
sort of feel like well if we had
to reignite the sun it
would mean the sun was out,
and if the sun was out,
we'd really be in bad shape.
So, probably most people who thought
about that first thought that if
that was the situation, I
wouldn't really be here,
so there really wouldn't be
much I could do about it.
But, I think that's a cool question.
>> STEPHANIE MARCUS:
Well, thanks again.
I guess we better stop and
if you want to come up,
he's got a few more minutes
before he has to get to a meeting.
Thank you [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.